Another clarification about rife use and foot baths. We get questions on a weekly basis about
the use of the rife and using other programs. Okay, so make this perfectly clear. The rife should
be your first go to for everything. Now, I do not believe the rife is a panacea for every disease,
no, to man, but it should be your first go to. I have an earache run the ear infection program.
I have, you know, use your use wisdom. If you broke your arm, don't try to run a program
of the rife to heal your heart, but it should be a go to program. I have a rash. I should run the
inflammation program or find a program that may be fitting. There's poison ivy, I think,
programs on the rife. So try to use the rife as a tool to help with any of your ills or any of your
problems without becoming a crazy hypochondriac that's that your husband divorces you because you're
sitting in front of the rife all the time. But it should be your first go to tool. You can't hurt
yourself running any programs on the rife. So use them. Clarification about the foot baths. Make sure
if you're using the foot bath apparatus, you are switching. Follow the instructions in your manual.
Flip the switch to bath and run only ion pro wave programs with your foot bath. Do not run
other programs with your foot bath. There are programs to be run with the bulb. That's 99% of the
programs on your rife. And then there's a folder that says ion pro wave. Those are the programs that
you can run with your foot bath. Now many of you, I have put an ion pro wave program that I want you
to run in your folder. Many of you, I have it. But the ones that have that in your folder, then run that
program. So just be clear about that. Look up your instructions. Every one of you is given a rife
manual spiral bound kind of thing. And just look that up if you're if you're unclear about that.
If you have to call the clinic, you can go ahead and do so.